le conseil d'état a donné raison au
gouvernement désormais la police et la
gendarmerie pourront afficher des
données telles que l'appartenance
syndicale ou politique des
renseignements sur la santé de très
nombreuses voix politique militante
associative s'était élevé contre ces
décrets alors plusieurs organisations
syndicales comme la cgt et fo la fsu
avait saisi le conseil d'état en urgence
est bien celui ci a estimé que la
collecte de ces données ne constituait
pas une atteinte à la liberté d'opinion
de conscience la liberté syndicale ou
encore la liberté de religion c'est à
dire que désormais police et gendarmerie
pourront collecter des photos ou des
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux
toute une foule de détails qui ne
figurait pas sur les fichiers
cela représente 50 types de données en
tout trois décrets pour trois types de
fichiers qui regroupe des dizaines de
milliers de personnes
alors jusqu'ici ces fichiers servait à
identifier des manifestants violent
encore des supporters de foot violent
désormais ils serviront aussi à
identifier des personnes susceptibles de
commettre un acte terroriste ou encore
et c'est là que le bât blesse de porter
atteinte à l'intégrité du territoire ou
aux institutions de la république et
cela laisse une grande marge de
manoeuvre ce que qui gênent énormément
les opposants à ce texte
on se rappelle qu'en 2008 françois
fillon avait dû reculer en voulant
instaurer un nouveau type de fichage le
fichier edvige sous la pression
populaire et aujourd'hui c'est un autre
type de big brother qui se profile